♪♪
Peter:
Give thanks to God.
♪♪
The Lord is with us.
What can a mere man do to me?
(Cage door slams shut)
♪♪
Son:
Papa!
I will come back to you!
♪♪
You walk the earth...
Fassel:
...because I let you.
♪♪
Fassel:
I'm your God now.
(Dog barks)
♪♪
Slaves are free.
Peter:
We must get to Baton Rouge.
Through the swamp.
♪♪
Peter:
Lincoln's army is there.
There are many ways to die in a
swamp.
(Gun-shot)
(Whistles)
(Dogs barking)
(Horses galloping)
♪♪
Peter:
I must get to my family.
♪♪
What if he don't come back?
Your papa is going to be back.
Dodienne:
Do not ever stop believing that.
He's persistent.
Fassel:
Running, hiding.
Surviving.
♪♪
(Canon fires)
Peter:
I fight them.
They beat me.
Peter:
They whip me.
They break the bones
Peter:
in my body
more times than I can count.
♪♪
But they never,
never break me.
♪♪
(Camera shutter clicks)
(Whistles)
♪♪